you know because for people who don't
know
you took the the clothing brand from
being downtown setting up shop in your
van that was always getting how many
times did this van get broken into
bruh the birdman get broken into at
least like two or three times a month
which just got gotta man that's cause
that's the thing i stayed in an
apartment building an apartment building
didn't have parking for the van it's
only you know it only had car parking so
i would park next door to my apartment
building in a parking lot and it was an
open public parking lot that you could
just pay and park your car and then i
would sit there all day grinding and
then at night you gotta understand half
of the break-ins was just smokers
just a smoker who i'll probably walk
past during the day see this
[ __ ] jumping come back at night
and ain't nobody there now they trying
to pry their way up in there and crazy
before i had it reinforced i had the
back door reinforced i had you know
these bands that go seat then it's open
so i had like a cage i literally built
the cage where i kept all the
merchandise
didn't stop them they'll break into it
just to try to steal some pennies out of
the out of the [ __ ] cup cup holder
yeah you know a shirt that's damaged
just sitting in the front you know
shirts are like 120 so they breaking in
trying to get a sock if they could they
don't care